tu es de nouvelles révélations du canard
enchaîné sur les appartements de la
ville de paris et sur la façon dont elle
gère son domaine privé le canard avait
déjà révélé qu alain juppé bénéficier
d'un six pièces dans le 6e
arrondissement à treize mille francs par
mois cette fois le canard va plus loin
il s'intéresse aux enfants du premier
ministre veut les engager et claude
sicard
je sais tout
mètres carrés au coeur de saint germain
des prés un appartement qui fait partie
du domaine privé de la ville de paris et
qu'ils nous près de 4500
j'attends un enfant très modérés
comparés aux prix pratiqués dans ce
quartier huppé
dans son édition à paraître demain le
canard explique que la rénovation de
l'appartement d'alain juppé à tous ces
beaux moments
france payée par la ville de paris
l'élève de may day révèle surtout que le
fils d'alain juppé innovants et le
géranium l'europe que celui souffert
également propriété de la ville de paris
il occupe depuis 80 ans
trois pièces de 80 m² entièrement rénové
nous mais aussi pour 1 2 ou 2 585 le
canard enchaîné plus de la directive
de la ville de paris destiné à l'egypte
il était alors adjoint au maire
selon ce document la ville serait à
l'origine de cet appartement de 5000
francs mais alain doutey aurait de sa
propre note réduit
ce soir le premier ministre ne souhaite
pas réagir